[Müzik]
size Bugün psikolojik sermayeden
bahsetmek istiyorum ve onun 4 bileşenini
anlatacağım Öz yeterlilik Umut
iyimserlik ve duygusal dayanıklılık
hayatın Bir celalli zamanları oluyor Bir
de cemalli zamanları oluyor ve bunların
üstesinden gelebilmek için güçlü bir
psikolojik sermayeye sahip olmak
hakikaten çok çok önemli
ve akşamın bu saatinde Sizler de biraz
yorulmuşsunuzdur diye tahmin ediyorum
psikolojik sermaye sunumuma başlamadan
önce şöyle duygusal durumumuz da aslında
çok hızlı oynayabiliyoruz bunu bir
beraber yapalım yan yana oturan kişiler
bir kişi abi olabilir mi Sen alsın Ben
de der misiniz Hemen şöyle bir AB
Evet ağlar Siz bir el kaldırır mısınız
lütfen
ağlar karşınızdaki kişi B bu ara
psikolojik sermayeden bayağı yemiş keyfi
yerinde olmayan mutsuz biri Lütfen bir
dönün Beylere bir tebessüm gönderin
Evet bak b'lerin hemen modunu
değiştirdiniz hemen yani bu kadar hızlı
Beyler inanın Siz daha iyisini
yapabilirsiniz Siz onlara bir Şen
kahkaha gönderin hadi
süpersiniz gerçekten şahanesiniz
ve psikolojik sermaye yatırımına bizim
Çok ihtiyacımız var Neden ihtiyacımız
var
Çünkü hayat bizi bir sürü şeyladın şimdi
bakın şu saydıklarımdan Herhangi birini
Hayatının bir döneminde yaşayanlar Ben
saydıkça lütfen ayağa kalkın ama yani
Şimdi milletin yanında göstermeyeyim
falan diye de düşünmeyin Çünkü
kırılganlığını gösterebilmek çok önemli
bir cesaret şimdi Ben saymaya başlıyorum
Bunlardan herhangi birini yaşadı sen
yaşadıysanız ayağa kalkıyorsunuz
herhangi bir şekilde sevgiliniz sizi
terk etti mi Bak kalkmıyorlar Kalkan
cesurlar Evet beni de terk etti hem de
kaç kere
boşandınız mı
Kalkın Evet
işte Hayır hayır ayakta kalın ayakta
kalın şimdi bakın ayakta kalın
Hayatının bir döneminde işsiz kalanlar
şimdi ayağa kalksın Evet şimdi Hayatının
bir döneminde parasız kalanlar kısa da
olsa yokluk çekenler fakirlik çekenler
Kalkın Evet şimdi
Hayatının bir döneminde Aldatılanlar
kalksın
evet hanımefendi cesaretinden Dolayı
kutluyorum
zor bir hastalığı atlatmak zorunda
kalanlar kalsın kalksın
Peki de Hayatının bir döneminde kaygı
bozukluğu ya da depresyon yaşayanlar
kalksın
Evet
ve
çok sevdiği birini Kaybedenler kalksın
yani ölenler
Evet gördünüz mü yok birbirimizden
farkımız neredeyse bütün salon ayağa
kalktık ve Siz kim bilir bunların
üstesinden nasıl da geldiniz
gösterdiğimiz Bu performansı hep beraber
bir ayakta alkışlayalım mı
Evet
[Alkış]
hemen fotoğraf çekin Şimdi niye Buyurun
lütfen Buyurun bu fotoğrafı niye
çektiriyorum onu da söyleyeyim Bu
fotoğrafı Instagram'a koyacağım
diyeceğim ki tedx konuşmam binlerce kişi
tarafından ayakta alkışlandı
Evet Bazen de böyle şey yaptırıyorum
eğitimlerden sonra diyorum ki şöyle bir
ellerimizi kaldıralım bir selam verelim
sonra beyler'e Diyorum ki bu Beşiktaş
selamıydı fenerbahçe'liler ve
Galatasaraylılar bir sinirleniyorlar
bana neyse konuya gireyim ben şimdi Öz
yeterlilikle başlayalım Öz yeterlilik
Albert bandura'nın ortaya attığı bir
kavram ve bandura diyor ki Öz
yeterliliği özgüvenle karıştırmayın Ben
Özgüven kavramından duyduğum
memnuniyetsizlikten dolayı Öz yeterlilik
kavramını ortaya attım diyor ve kavram
bizim ne kadar yeterli olduğumuz ile
ilgili değil kendimizi ne kadar yeterli
algılıyoruz acaba
yeteneklerimize becerilerimize
yapabilirdiklerimize olan inancımız
nedir acaba ve bu o kadar önemli bir
beceri ki gerçekten birkaç boyutu ile de
iyileştirilebiliyor 4 tane çalışma
yapmamız gerekiyor Bunun için Birincisi
olumlu yaşantılar gerçekten çok çok
önemli geçmişte Neyi yaptıysak oraya bir
tik atmak yapamadıklarımızla ilgili ise
adım atmaya cesaret etmek cesaret çok
değişik bir duygu kullanılmadığı zaman
azalıyor ama yaptığın zaman da dönüp
şunu diyebilmek çok önemli Aferin yaptım
ya Şimdi yanınızdakine çok gurur
duyduğunuz bir başarınızı ya hayatta bir
zaferinizi söyler misiniz yanınızdaki
kişiye şununla çok gurur duyuyorum tik
attım oraya diye bir söyler misiniz
buyurun
[Müzik]
yok mu vardır bir şeyler ya olmaz mı
Evet
Şimdi bunu konuşmak bile
Sevgili dostlar şimdi benim süremden de
gitmesin zamana da uyuyayım ben
geçmiş yaşantılarımıza şöyle bir bakmak
arada onlarla ilgili gurur duymak
Bunları anlatmak narsizme kapılmadan
yapabiliyorsanız Gerçekten çok faydalı
sabah imposter fenomeninden bahsedildi
gerçekten özellikle kadınlarda çok
yaygın bir şekilde görülüyor imposter
fenomeni yani ne yaparsam yapayım olmadı
Hep bir şey eksik hissi buradan çıkış Öz
yeterlilik için önemli Öz yeterlidir
için ikinci şey dolaylı deneyimler Hani
o yaptıysa ben de yaparım bugünkü
konuşmacıların büyük bir çoğunluğu ilham
alınacak insanlar bulmanın rol model
edinmenin ne kadar önemli olduğunu
söylediler gerçekten çok çok doğru ve
ben lise yıllarında ortaokul yıllarında
Daha doğrusu Okul hayatım boyunca hiçbir
zaman çok parlak bir öğrenci olmadım
Ortalama bir öğrenci idim fiziksel
görünümüm hasebiyle de böyle insanların
çok ilgisini çeken çok çekici çok hoş
bir genç kız değildim
bir sınıf arkadaşım vardı o da benim tam
tersi sınıfın en başarılısı en güzeli
vesaire Neyse sonra zaman geçti 2-3 sene
önce tesadüfen bir Ankara'ya gittiğimde
Çankaya'da bununla yolda karşılaştık
işte hasbihane diyoruz falan hani o
dolaylı deneyimler kısmında Aklımda
kalan bir hatıra yaşattı bana dedi ki
Vallahi ben dedi Hülyacığım dedi seni
dedi bizim çocuklara da dedi anlatıyorum
dedi Ben de dedi düşünüyorum dedi Hülya
bu vasatlıkla bunları yaptıysa
biz daha neler yaparız
de hep
erkeklere Bugün yüklendik de peki
kadının kadına yaptığı zorbalık O ne
olacak
değil mi
hakikat
hakikat ona sırtımızı döndüğümüz sürece
iyileşmez cam tavanlar bizi tabii ki
şifalandırmaz ama Yankı odaları da bir o
kadar tehlikeli diye düşünüyorum
bu sözlü ikna başkalarının takdirleri ve
taltifleri bize çok iyi geliyor o yüzden
takdir eder beğenir diye arada düşünmek
lazım Ve birbirimizi de takdir
edebilmeliyiz hadi hemen size tekrar
söyleyeyim yanınızdakini tanımıyorsanız
bile dönün bir şeyi takdir edin
tanıyorsanız sevdiğiniz bir özelliğini
seni şu özelliğini takdir ediyorum
Buyurun bir söyleyin ya
Evet
Sevgili dostlar
şimdi bakın
yine süremden almayın
Ben Ankara'da emniyet müdürlerine böyle
kalabalık bir gruba konuşma yaptım ve
dedim ki işte polisleri de takdir edin
eşlerinizi de takdir edin falan emniyet
müdürlerinden biri çok gaza geliyor
öğlen otele yakın bir yerde oturuyor
gidiyor eşine konuşmaya başlıyor 20
yıldır çok kahrımı çektin Seni çok
seviyorum çocuklara çok iyi annelik
ettin annem gibi zor bir kadını benim
gibi zor bir adamı çektin sen şöyle
takdir edilesi böyle kadın böyle bakıyor
diyor ki Beytullah sen ne halt ettin
çabuk söyle
şimdi Yani o kadar alışmamış ki diyor ki
hocam evliliğimden olacaktım ya dedim bu
bu kadar az yapılmaz ne olur birbirimizi
sıkça takdir edelim o zaten Biliyor diye
düşünmeyelim Öz yeterli diye çok katkısı
var ve son boyutu ise duygusal durum
duygusal durum şöyle Profesör Doktor
Engin gençten rahmetle analım diyor ki;
kendi içinde devrik olmayan birini
devirmeye hiç kimsenin gücü yetmez ve o
bize Bebekken daha yüklenmiş olan
yetersizlik duygusu burada anne ve
babalarımız yüklemiyor bu defa yüklenen
bir şey yani 2 yıl başkalarına muhtacız
Bu bize özellikle stresli ve
belirsizliklerin arttığı dönemlerde
kırılgan yapabiliyor bununla yüzleşmek
duygusal okuryazarlığımızı geliştirmek
gerçekten çok önemli Öz yeterlilikle
ilgili anlatacaklarım Burada şimdi Umuda
doğru gidelim Umut diğer duygularla
karşılaştırıldığında enter iki özelliğe
sahip birisi nesnesi gelecekte yani
ileride iyi şeylerin olacağına inanmak
ikincisi diğer olumlu duygular gibi huşu
içinde olduğumuz zamanlarda ortaya
çıkmıyor zorlukta ortaya çıkıyor Şu sözü
çok severim sırtını asfalta yaslayan
çocuk pamuk döşeklerde uyuyan çocuktan
çok daha umut vardır bir zorluk varsa
bir hastalık varsa parasızlık yokluk
sıkıntı aşksızlık varsa Umut oluyor peki
Nasıl umut var olabiliriz Madem
ülkemizin psikolojisi bu kadar bozulmuş
Şimdi birincisi şu; Hayal etmemiz
gerekiyor Türkiye'de de dünyada da
yetişkinlerin önemli bir kısmı Hayal
etmeyi bırakıyor
bir gelecek vizyonunu zihnimizde
canlandırdığımızda Bu bir niyet oluyor
niyet adaleti alıyor Atalet cesareti
getiriyor cesaret hareketi getiriyor
hareket bir bereketi getiriyor
Dolayısıyla Her şey hayal etmekle
başlıyor ve hayalin tarlasında ürün de
boldur hasatta Ama sen yeter ki hayal et
olur diyerek de konuyu indirgemeyeceğim
Çünkü ekmediğimiz yerden dermek mümkün
değil
Umut teorisinin babası Sneijder diyor ki
Hayal ettiniz Tamam alın hayallerinizi
hedefe dönüştürün ve kavramsallaştırın
Ve sonra diyor stratejik yol haritaları
çizin Çünkü bizi ara sıra yaptıklarımız
değil düzenli olarak yaptıklarımız
dönüştürecek ve son olarak da diyor ki;
eyleme geçin
dikdörtle insanın anlam arayışı
kitabının yazarı varoluşçu Psikolojinin
önemli isimlerinden biri diyor ki
Amerika'ya dikilen özgürlük heykelinin
karşısına Keşke bir de sorumluluk
heykeli dikilseydi bakın hayatımızın
sorumluluğunu aldığımızda seçimlerimizin
sorumluluğunu aldığımızda yeniden bazı
şeyleri tanımlamaya karar verdiğimiz ise
hayat bambaşka yüzünü göstermeye
başlıyor Umut gidelim iyimserliğe ve
iyimserlik tarafında ise Martin
zaligmanı anmadan geçemeyiz iyimserliğin
babası o şöyle söylüyor diyor ki
iyimserlik Ya şu an iyi giden ne var iyi
olan ne var
nelere yönümüzü çevirebiliriz bir
arkadaşım dedi ki vallahi Hiçbir şey iyi
gitmiyor ülkede Şöyle evde böyle işte
şöyle hiçbir şey iyi gitmiyor dedim ki
bak Yunus nazarından Bak şöyle söylüyor
Hak bir gönül vermiş bana ha demeden
hayran olur birden gelir Şadan olur
birden gelir geryan olur Onun bakışından
bakabilsek ağlayan bir bebeğin sesi bizi
rahatsız etmeyecek soğuk da bizi
rahatsız etmeyecek yokluk da bizi
rahatsız etmeyecek nasıl aşarız diye
bakmaya başlayacağız şimdi tabii
iyimserliği de
teşvik etmek için bizim de eğitimlerde
yaptırdığımız bazı çalışmalar var Ben
2003 yılında bir eğitime katıldım Hoca
dedi ki
yeterlik Özgüven bunları böylece
coşturacağımız bir çalışma yapalım ama
birbirinize etkileyeceksiniz dedi bizi
böyle eşleştirdi bana da bir partner
atandı Bir haftadır falan aynı eğitimde
olduğumuz bir beyefendi düştü karşıma ve
böyle karşılıklı birbirimize iltifatlar
takdirler sunacağız daha iyimser bir
moda taşıyacağız Şimdi adam bana baktı
Dedi ki senin dedi Biliyor musunuz
saçların çok güzel aa teşekkür ederim
dedim Gözlerinde çok güzel dedi Sağ olun
dedim bak dedim bakıyorum burnun da
güzel
ama dedi hepsini toplayınca ortaya Çok
güzel bir şey çıkmıyor
bak dedi sonra fenel Efe Cruz da senin
gibi mesela dedi ayrı ayrı güzel ama
bütünde çirkin şimdi bazısı
iyimserlikten O kadar uzak ki olmuyor
olmuyor
Martin zeligman diyor ki kalıcı bakmayın
Efendim Gerçekten bu geçici dünyanın
hiçbir sorunu Kalıcı değil bugün Bu
salonda üzüldüğünüz bir şey varsa size
söyleyeyim geçecek biliyorsunuz ikincisi
diyor ki; kapsayıcı bakmayın Sen zaten
hep böylesin Hayır bugün sabah böyleydin
ve diyor kişiselleştirmeyin indirgenmiş
indirgenmiş kendilik algısı iyi bir şey
değil değildir ve oradan duygusal
dayanıklılığa gidelim nedir bu duygusal
dayanıklılık düştün yeniden kalkabiliyor
musun Eyvah benim düzenim bozuldu değil
bu düzen değişti yeni düzende Acaba ne
yapabilirim diyebiliyor musun Atatürk'ün
Sabiha Gökçen'e yazdığı bir mektuba denk
geldim ve beni çok etkilemişti şöyle
söylüyor Gökçen yapılacak işlerin
büyüklüğü ve azameti karşısında insan
ömrü cüce kalıyor çok şeyler başarmak
istiyorum Lakin büyük bir savaştan
çıktık şimdi ekonomik anlamda bir savaş
veriyoruz ama benim bir amacım var
Ankara'da İstanbulda İzmir'de nasıl bir
mamur yaşayan varsa bunu Anadolu'nun her
köşesine ama her köşesini taşımayı çok
istiyorum İşte hayatın ortasına böyle
anlamlı bir amacı oturtursak
zorlandığımız zamanlarda engelleri aşmak
için bir sürü yol bir sürü seçenek
olduğunu da görebiliriz Peki anlamı
nasıl buluruz İngilizce bir formül var
Live formülü size şimdi Plaza işi
yapmayacağım kendim skeçlerimdeki gibi
ama bunların baş harfi ile gideceğim
layvan'ın l'si diyor ki bu vatan Love
Ben neyi çok seviyorum Mihail çık sen
mihaliç akış kitabında diyor ki; kendini
böyle akışta hissettiğin zamanın nasıl
geçtiğini anlam olduğum zamanları Yakala
senin için orada mutluluk var ikincisi
inner giftelens sana bahşedilen
yetenekler ve beceriler neler nice bize
yeryüzüne ihanet etmememizi öneriyor
Bence yeryüzüne ihanetin en büyüğü kendi
yeteneklerine ihanet etmek ve
kullanmamak Livan v'si
hangi değerleri onurlandıran bir hayat
yaşarsam bu hayatın hakkını gerçekten
vermiş olacağım ve laybın e'si
envaryumand hangi çevrede kimlerin
olduğu ortamda ben içimdeki en iyi
ortaya çıkarabileceğim
şimdi konuşmamı bir hikaye ile
tamamlayacağım ama daha biraz daha
anlatacağım bu hikayeyi bu kıssayı
Sizler de biliyorsunuzdur Pers
mitolojisinden simurg'un hikayesi ben
onu biraz psikolojik sermaye ile
ilişkilendirerek anlatacağım simur
kuşların Efendisi ve kuşlar onu bir
kurtarıcı gibi görüyor Çünkü küllerinden
yeniden doğabilme özelliğine haiz bunun
için Kaf Dağı'na gidip Onu bulmaya karar
veriyorlar ve önlerinde çok uzun bir yol
var bizim hayat yolumuza çok
benzetiyorum ben bu yolculuğu ve o
vadiler kuşların bazılarının helak
olmasına sebebiyet veriyor O vadileri
iyi tanımak lazım ilk Vadi nefs Vadisi
bu vadede Biz insan yavrusu da aynı o
kuşlar gibi benim olsun edineyim alayım
ya Oysa bize iyi gelen vermek değil mi
şimdi dervişin biri Allah'a bulmak için
yola çıkıyor bir tepeye geliyor O kadar
yorulmuş ki Ya Rabbi diyor Şu fakir
kuluna bir eşek göndersen de ben bu
Tepeyi öyle çıksam pat geliyor bizimki
bir seviniyor tepesine biniyor o arada
bir eşkıya beliriyor Bana bak diyor sen
diyor Derviş misin Evet diyor Ben
dervişlerden nefret ederim garip bir
tevazu insanlara ne yapmaları
gerektiğini sürekli söylemek haline bak
utanmıyor musun küçücük eşeğin tepesine
binmişsin in çabuk diyor sen onu sırtına
alacağım ve bu Tepeyi o şekilde
çıkaracaksın kılıcını kınından çıkarınca
bizimki çok korkuyor çaresiz sırtına
alıyor eşeği ve kan ter içinde o Tepeyi
çıkarıyor işte biz de bazen nefsimize
öyle bir imtihana düşüyoruz ki Olsun
olsun ama ne olursa olsun Oysa şunu
unutmamak lazım bazen nefsimizi Ağır
gelen bir bakıyoruz ki Evet ya Benim
için hayırlıymış ve unutmayalım bize iyi
gelecek olan biriktirmek değil vermek ve
paylaşmak Kul Himmet ne güzel söylüyor
söz söylersin söz içinde sözün var
çalarsın çırparsın oğlun kızın var Şu
Dünyada Üç beş arşın bezin var tüm
Bedesten senin olsa ne yazar Kuşlar
ikinci vadiye geçiyorlar Aşk Vadisi
burada duygularını yönetemiyorlar Biz de
bazen bazı duyguların içinde çok uzun
kalıyoruz ve onları dönüştüremiyoruz
duygular muhteşem varlıklar olumsuzu
yoktur hepsinin bilgi vermek amacı
vardır o bilgiyi görüp dönüştürebilmek
gerekir hangi duygular onlar Haset fesat
kıskançlık umutsuzluk Çaresizlik
Yalnızlık suçluluk öfke
bunları kapılmak yerine Bu duygu bir
bilgi veriyor içinde ne kadar kalmalıyım
duygusal okuryazarlık yetkinliğimizi
geliştirmekte fayda var ve üçüncü Vadi
cehalet Vadisi bu vadide Kuşlar diyor ki
ya biz artık öğrendik bizim biz olduk
biz olduk diyen Aslında biz öldük diyor
öğrenmeyi bırakmamak gerçekten çok ama
çok önemli Alvin tofler 21 yüzyılın
cahili Okuma yazmayı bilmeyenler değil
öğrenmeyi bilmeyenler olacaktır diyor ve
öğrenmenin sorumluluğunu okullara
çalıştığınız yerlere ya da
şirketlerinizin akademilerine asla ve
kat daha devretmeyin diyorum ve diğer
taraftan
Aşık Veysel diyor ki cahil olan Gül olsa
da Koklama
ve ondan sonraki Vadi inançsızlık Vadisi
Albert kamu sanat ve edebiyatın olduğu
bir yerde umutsuzluğa yer yoktur diyor
Buraya gelen Kuşlar sayıları iyice
azalmış yorulmuş bitap düşmüş Biz de
bazen bir yola çıkarız ama yolda şöyle
olur ya bu Olmayacak galiba ya ben
yapamayacağım nefesim tükendi
1914'ten sesleniyor edebiyatçı bakın
diyor ki atiyi karanlık görüverince
apıştın esbabı elinden de atarak yese
yapıştın Yes öyle bir bataktır ki
düşersen boğulursun ümide sarıldım sıkı
seyret ne olursun ve Nazım da sonu
tatlıya bağlanan kitaplar ve masallar
istiyor bizden o zaman inançsızlık
vadisinde helak olmayalım ve sonraki
Vadi Yalnızlık Vadisi
kuşlardan bazıları yalnız uçmaya
başlıyor ve ötekinden uzaklaşıyor İnsan
insanın kurdudur diye bir laf duyuyorum
Hayır efendim İnsan insanın yurdudur ve
bizim dertlerimizi birbirimizin gönlünde
dinlendirmeye bir muhtaçlığımız var
pandemi ile beraber çok uzaklaştık
birbirimizden ve o dertleri kaygıları
sıkıntıları paylaştığımız zaman azalıyor
Freud'un kaygıyı anlattığı bir makalede
şöyle söylüyor diyor ki; bir gün
Viyana'da Bir otelde Otel Karanlığa
gömüldü ve ben bakıyorum böyle yan odada
küçük bir kız 3-4 yaşlarında halasıyla
beraber ağlamaya başladı hala çok
korkuyorum çok karanlık halası onu
teskin etmeye çalıştı Korkma bebeğim
birazdan aydınlanacak Ben buradayım
sonra sustu diyor kız dedi ki hala
konuşmaya devam eder misin kadın şöyle
söyledi konuşmam neyi değiştirecek Sen
konuştuğunda Burası bana Daha aydınlık
geliyor birbirimizle konuşalım
Karanlıklar daha aydınlık oluyor ve
sonra sıradaki Vadi sondan bir önceki
Vadi dedikodu Vadisi o onun
Biz simurguz biri pandeminin başlarında
dedi ki Hülya ben kaderimin üzerinde
kontrolümü kaybettim var mı Kader
üstünde kontrolümüz Sizce bilmiyorum 800
yıl önce geliyor cevap Diyor ki Kader
yolun tamamını değil sadece yol
ayrımlarını verir sapak ve dönemeçler
yolcuya aittir Öyleyse ne kaderinin
hakimisin ne de Kader karşısında
Külliyen çaresiz Efendim ömrünüzün kalan
kısmında elinizden gelenin en iyisini
yaptığınız ve psikolojik sermayenizi
sürekli artırdığınız günleriniz olsun
Ben hepinizi saygıyla selamlıyorum İyi
ki varsınız
var olun